président pas question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
j'associe mais que mes collègues
girondins à cette question le massif
forestier des landes de gascogne brûlent
les feux sont particulièrement violent
dans les secteurs de landiras et de la
teste de buch qu'il s'agisse de forêt
usagère ou à visée économique la forêt
brûle aussi en finistère monts d'arrée
et dans le sud-est de gigantesques feux
en ravagé presque 19 milles 370 ha à
cette heure de végétation soit presque
deux fois la surface de paris malgré les
importants moyens déployés un troisième
feu s'est déclaré hier dans le médoc des
évacuations préventives des communes
sont réaliser vous même monsieur le
ministre
madame la secrétaire d'état bérengère
couillard et le président du sénat
gérard larcher se sont rendus sur place
et je vous en remercie
je tiens bien sûr à saluer aussi devant
vous tous chers collègues le dévouement
extraordinaire des élus locaux des mères
leurs conseillers municipaux des
services de l'état du département de la
région nouvelle aquitaine
est évidemment le travail des soldats du
feu qui est tout simplement et oraux
héroïque de jour comme de nuit
merci pour eux un mot également pour les
forestiers qui ont mis à disposition
leur équipe les hommes leur matériel
pour combattre le feu mais aussi ne
l'oublions pas la préfet de lucio les
sous-préfets furie fériés loustics qui
sont exceptionnelles la sécurité civile
adf ces îlots nf tout simplement les
citoyens et la formidable solidarité
entre tous ont travaillé de jour comme
de nuit notre devoir est d'agir pour la
suite face aux grands feux des actions
de prévention sont essentiels il faut
apprendre à retrouver des usages
respectueux de la forêt former les
citoyens sanctionner durement les actes
criminels notons aussi que les moyens
des fds disent si précieux s'appuie sur
une cartographie qui date de 2002 et qui
méritent d'être mises à jour avec
l'accroissement de la population
collègues je vous remercie